okay well for people who are joining us
on the live stream this is another
episode and our continuing design of
chemistry functionality a form of
language so without further ado let's
get started
okay molecule and graph functions okay
[Music]
so the issue is what is the issue here
is to make specifically a chemical graph
that is different from an ordinary graph
really you guys there sorry I thought it
was unmuted so graph has lots of named
constructors like complete graph or
Peterson graph and this would be a
molecule graph that would produce a
graph object sounds good to me
and it's an ordinary graph object in
other words things like double bonds are
represented how either as multi edges or
as properties on the edges I don't know
which would be better or they could be
weights okay but grant the graph in the
wulfing language is very versatile and
you can have properties at the holder
here okay yes what do you think we
should do with respect to double bonds
and grubs I think we need at least at
this stage I think we need to be able to
play with both okay and Michael is
probably right but yeah these two should
be the right a double bond function or
something how do we specify so double
bonds in the case of a molecule instead
of a instead of a two-way rule for an
edge right you should have a double bond
there instead is that right there was
symbolic double bond thing right okay so
really what we want is probably an edge
conversion function
or something or a bond convert I mean
one way to do it would be to say you
know to have a bond conversion
I mean the same applies to the notes you
might want to preserve some of the nodes
in the it some properties its weights
okay but there's a node right but that's
something like which atom is this which
type of atom is this right so something
like when you go from the from the atom
node to the vortex of a cough you might
want to preserve some things you might
want to put the atomic mass as the
weight or you might want to just have it
as a property right when you label it
with mr. NAAC yeah if this is a function
then all of these things can be
accommodated which is great you know but
I think we need to work through sort of
assess our useful mapping but we have
some named mappings here so in other
words all conversion function OB it will
be at some conversion function or what
right and so so we would take an actual
function or ever take a name I think it
would take various kinds of curated
names the two commonly useful things but
I think in general it could take a
function that operates on the canonical
atom specifier and converts it I mean
there's a fully decorated form of both
on Ataman and bond isn't there right so
a bond is could just be bond list 1
comma 2 strings single or equivalently
single bond 1 comma 2
well whatever gets fed to the bond
conversion function better have been
canonicalize we better decide what the
canonical form is otherwise people will
have to write all kinds of crazy stuff
there
right we better decide what is the I
mean doesn't doesn't molecule
canonicalize to some definite form right
so so the way I have it now you can you
can say single bond double bond aromatic
bond just for convenience but then the
canonicalize form its bond comma
aromatic bond bond Co what do you mean
bond list 1 comma 2 and then a string
like bond like this yes and then single
like that right okay yeah okay fine well
then the bond conversion function what
what how else can you decorate the bond
that's really the only property that we
have how do you specify an anthem so the
head Adam follow then the single
arguments and Association okay atomic
number goes to 2 3 it's a bad example
formal charge goes to 2 - okay so that
you have something like this so then in
principle the yeah so so we have to
figure out how these functions I mean we
could generally have bond conversion
function anthem conversion function
could be useful for other things as well
for example for various kinds of
exporting I would imagine maybe probably
not I think handling the mime types for
the different formats would be an easier
way to go there aren't that many
different formats anyway I see okay fun
also about these conversion functions
would they be a lot like the graph
vertex label and edge label functions in
the way they would be perhaps used were
specified I don't really know because I
mean
yeah I mean another question hydrogen's
are the only things that get you know
emitted there's nothing else that you
sort of emit because you don't feel like
including it right it's not like so
hydrogen's I take a make up behalf of
the vertices but give you almost no new
information so they're often omitted
mm-hmm okay well so I can't tell you
exactly do you want to discuss these any
further or does this give a reasonable
direction for what right I think that's
a reasonable direction we can come up
with names like a order to wait or order
to bond order to property something like
that I can have that a few different
options for those things for the next
meeting okay okay so at the last meeting
it was suggested that adjacency matrix
would just simply take a molecule and
work on it but given the the different
conversion options
it doesn't seem unreasonable to have to
convert it to a graph before feeding it
to these functions well so long as the
Jason C matrix can give a meaningful
message in other words is there a
canonical ordering of atom I mean in
other words which is atom number one two
three four five is that obvious no I
mean it's it's only obvious in the
expression that you that you had there
listed in that order you can also see
them on a molecule plot or something but
no I mean we have a canonicalization or
we can have a canonical form of the
molecule but we don't always we don't
reorder atoms to be the in the canonical
form what I'm asking is to make a
meaningful adjacency matrix
it matters what order the atoms are in
right absolutely okay so given a
molecule in a given a particular
representational molecule is it obvious
what the ordering is yes from a
particular expression that you're given
the ordering is obvious what's not
obvious there is whether to include
hydrogen's or not and I don't think that
you'd want to give a new option to these
functions
whether to include hydrogen's or not now
the important thing though is if you ask
for the adjacency matrix then ask for
the atom list that they're consistent
yes
look my co-chairing will be if we can
make adjacency matrix just work we might
as well but I think it would also be
perfectly acceptable to generate a
custom error message that says you know
given that there's a molecule inside
that you have to and you're asking for
the adjacency matrix which you might
reasonably expect would work that it
says you have to convert to a graph
first but we just don't want to leave it
with the adjacency matrix of a molecule
just prettiest in garbage right okay
yeah fine shortest tour why would why
would one care about that let's I that
one I don't know in particular but like
what's the shortest path to really come
from one atom to and also especially for
with a torus to connect to yourself
right
so the shortest tour might matter for
people who were looking at molecular
circuits or electron paths okay molecule
okay
anomalous bond list I agree don't have a
problem with that I mean it's a little
unfortunate our whole atom atom q yeah
I mean it is conceivable that we should
slowly deprecated atom q and replace it
with some other name because that's the
only place where we use the word atom to
mean something that isn't physical atoms
oh gosh it's from version one how is it
updated in 2003 I mean
could imagine leaf akyuu well though we
might just be setting ourselves up for
another unhappiness in a few years it's
a little weird at some list because you
know that could mean something for an
expression
it's like level gamma minus one the
leaves right but the alternative then is
vertex list point my point would be to
create a new thing that does the
functionality of atom queue and slowly
slowly slowly deprecated the atom q
function do you understand yeah Michael
do you have any opinions about that I
think it's a very important function
also of course it confuses people a lot
claim that they see something can't get
insert yeah but I mean to say that it's
an atom it's really a question of
whether it is whether it's a leaf I
don't know I I mean really the question
is can you can you operate respond it
this is the one that medals to people
yeah where I can you split the atom I
mean I've always wished that it was
called normal Q instead of atom Q but it
atom Q is what it is called normal Q
wouldn't be the right name the reverse
of this right oblique you what's that
it split oblique you indivisible Q say
indivisible Q I don't think indivisible
is right it's what can you go inside I'm
reminded of the first common notion of
Euclid a point is that which has no part
that's what we're dealing with here I
mean does in some sense if we can split
the integers and the reals
yes but not by I mean what it really is
I part right it's really a special
function for part yes I mean it's sort
of sub parts q does it have sub parts
part accessible part part of it yeah
right the truth is in code when people
say atom Q in a piece of code if it was
more descriptive it would actually help
because for people who don't know the
kind of history of you know anthems and
Lisp or God knows what else
it's not very helpful to see Adam q you
have to always explain it whereas if we
had a name which explained it we would
be better off um well you picked first
and rest instead of Karan cutter yeah
but that's it isn't that good good like
first and rest much better not get that
reference what's that I don't get the
reference missile is this they called
car and cutter yeah as a result of
machine instructions on a what an IBM
704 or something yes I'm 604 maybe um I
mean
language is full of historical not our
not Wolfen language but the English is
full of historical crud and okay
in any case I think it's a serious
possibility that we should try and come
up with a better name for Adam Q and I
think it should be something about parts
part the partition comes to my partition
Q but that is close to our partition
absolutely not there's a partitions q
function which is one of those rare
functions that ends with a cubit isn't a
question okay
accessible I mean look this is probably
the most descriptive of the names part
accessible queue um let's bring this up
we have an LCC meeting that follows
immediately this one maybe um you see
whose p.m. in that meeting maybe not
today because already the last time the
subject the attend was delayed okay
therefore it okay fine um okay well can
we get it on the LCC agenda then first I
have ordered and also maybe maybe send
it to t2 to the design mailing list and
yep maybe here I'll send you these not
very good names yeah um I actually like
the idea of renaming it because every
time I've shown Adam clear to people
they say what is that which is kind of
not the answer you want and you know
when we have an atom list and it has to
do with molecules nobody is going to ask
what is that um otherwise somebody is
heavy breathing okay alright I small for
some functions chemistry where
isomorphic molecule q what is the what
is the graph isomorphism thing as a
graph isomorphic graph q okay okay so
the idea here is with a molecule if
they're not isomorphic if the bonds
don't match if the charges if the atom
type doesn't match up sure okay
it doesn't seem wrong to me I mean the
okay so find molecule isomorphism is
that is there a fine graph isomorphism
yes and it returns a list of rules that
map the vertices yep okay and what would
you return here the same map how do you
apply that list
I mean in other words in the case of a
graph how do you even apply that
isomorphism list in the case of a graph
Roger
um do you mean by applying well I mean
if I wanted to take that first graph
there and you know apply this
isomorphism to it to get the second
graph how would I do that given that's
that first graph structure look in the
application I think you this you just
remapping the vertex names it's a big
mess
Wow whatever I don't know what the heck
this is showing well look under scope
then I mean what would you just
remapping their vertices
you're just reordering the vertices yeah
it's not what you're doing but I'm
asking you
structurally how do you take it I mean I
can't just say slash dot and then
replace those numbers because I do
bonkers things that way you would have
to take the vertex list and take its
part you could take the vertex list in
the edge list and do it so the answer is
there isn't a very good way I mean in
other words this is the analog of some
kind of replaced part but there is such
a thing hold on for graphs yes so what
you mean artex replace or somesuch
but so it isn't even referenced and
phone calls isomorphism okay so but
that's my question is how do you use the
phone I mean other words what would you
do so you look at the molecule
isomorphism you say oh that's wonderful
yes these things I mean sort of a proof
that there is an isomorphic isomorphism
between those molecules but then so what
write to me the isomorphic molecule q is
the more important of the two functions
if you want the isomorphism map why
would you want it tell me one reason you
wanted other than to be convinced that
it's true that there's an isomorphism
it's important if you're trying to
determine the symmetry of the molecule
it helps construct the permutation group
for example okay so explain that to me
so that permutation group
is very directly like the this is a
permutation right the the isomorphism is
a permutation yes how does it relate to
quotes the permutation group of a
molecule if you have all of the
permutations you just have to add the
identity to it and then you've got the
permutation group the communication
group is used in a number of
applications of isomer counting and
things like that
possibly entropy calculations okay but
so for those things would you be taking
the molecule and then effectively
applying a permutation to its atoms and
then expect you to get back to another
molecule or what's the deal in my
experience we haven't done that but we
have used a permutation group to count
isomers and different pathways have been
reconverting labeled isomers so in an
area where I've used the finding the
isomorphism map itself is so when I was
getting SD files from pubchem they would
have a 2d and a 3d for each molecule to
show the diagram and the 3d structure
but they would they would sometimes have
the the atoms in a different order and I
still wanted to get the 3d coordinates
from pubchem so I had to use that map in
the the method manner that's not so
super convenient but really what you
want is you know conform one molecule to
another molecule right like I'm like an
atom and between right but in particular
and I would even argue that that would
be true for graphs also in other words
ever insert vertex replaced even but
that is I'm gonna fix that there should
be a reference to it yeah and probably
in properties and relations here so
vertex replace does what we would hope
it would do yes okay my one question
though Steven is once you take this
permutation and you apply it from one
structure to another
what do you get in the end you get
something that's I that's for all
intents and purposes identical all the
properties you would compute from it
would be the same about the only thing
that might be different would be the
atom labels
I'm not sure though they might be they
might have different embeddings so the
coordinates wouldn't we'll just the
labels and the bonds and so on would
move or something like that but the I
mean this is okay okay isomorphic
molecule q for example if there was
something labeled it's going to ignore
the label for purposes of molecule
isomorphism correct yes it's not totally
obvious it should do that in other words
you could have a thing which says lock
this particular thing maybe maybe I'm
wrong am I wrong
so you mean specifying which properties
are considered in the isomorphic like
don't use their formal charge do
consider formal charge yes we won't ask
you but I mean I I'm just trying to
understand it could be that for some
exogenous reason the one little iron
atom no of course with one iron atom you
know which which never mind I mean I'm
then then you know where it is so to
speak let's say there are two iron atoms
and for some exogenous reason you know
that this iron atom can't be exchanged
does that make any sense or I might just
mean confusing maybe it doesn't make any
sense but then the question is so you're
saying isomorphism of molecules throws
away annotations but doesn't throw away
physical properties like this is such
and such an isotope and so on I believe
that's the way most people would expect
it to behave to be used I I've only seen
it used as a test as it were I've never
actually seen the permutation being used
and applied on one structure or another
yeah I mean all I'm saying is I think
finding the permutation is basically a
proof
yeah the only application I can think of
is if he did it on substructures and you
wanted to align two three-dimensional
structures on a subset of the atoms and
you would want to find the mapping from
one molecule to another automatically
and then bring the two structures in the
same 3d space with those atoms
superimposed but as Jason was saying he
needed to use it too for almost that
application of 2d 3d yes yes and so
there could be a function renumber atoms
cuz this vertex replace can do a lot
more vertex replace can take a vertex
and replace it with a new vertex that
wasn't there whereas here we're just
talking about reordering if you apply an
isomorphism to a molecule you would just
be reordering the atoms so you could
just have reorder atoms or renumber
atoms is it renumber or reorder the
atoms have to the atoms the atoms have
numbers yes yes they're usually referred
to by their by their index in their
position in the list so to be named
couldn't right you could also also yeah
so what do you do if it's a named if
it's a molecule with named atoms what
does fine molecule isomorphism then does
it end up in its list of rules having
things like you know the X goes to Y
type thing as opposed to 3 goes to 17 I
would think it would have to be the 3
goes to 17 to be completely unambiguous
and those labels x and y would just be
carried along wait a minute the labels
but but is it obvious I don't even
understand does every atom have a
positional label or do some atoms
potentially have labels which are just
explicit labels as opposed to positional
labels no everyone is a positional label
and some atoms also were given a name
when you created them and they can be
referred to by the name okay but the
name is just decoration and will be
carried along but it's not part of the
yeah so I mean the name I don't quite
understand if if I've got some you know
three carbon atoms and one of them has a
name
two of them have names - those become
their non identical carbons that can't
be interchanged in an isomorphism
calculation no but that we could make it
an option to include names but I would
assume not notice you but then after
you've done the find isomorphism then
you moved a named atoms at one position
to another okay so the issue here is do
we need a function that says to return
the map well the map is to find molecule
isomorphism question is right that's
that's returning the map the question is
what what applies the map and that's
your renumber reorders sounds better
yeah sounds better to me - and which is
vertex replace in the case of of graphs
that is the analog of vertex replace
which would eat to find graph
isomorphism output yes okay all right
well I mean I you know for the time
being we could say molecule I don't know
what the molecule reorder or something
molecule I don't know whether I mean we
could call it molecule reorder something
like that okay I can work on I can make
that up we have something called a
canonical graph what does that mean it
it's just a normal form of it so if you
you know it's isomorphic to the original
graph and and it just uses canonical
labeling mm-hmm always one two three and
so on
two two graphs are isomorphic only if
they're their canonical graphs are same
Q writer is that yes okay let's OD I
mean are you proposing that there be a
canonical molecule as well I don't know
I mean it's kind of useful when you want
to compare a graph a large collection of
them yeah you know and it's that's sort
of a big use case for you know canonical
graph can we overload the gall functions
here for molecules right the functions
that end in the word graph do we want to
really know right but some functions I
would like to use like connected
components specifically connected
components returns a list of graphs I
don't see any problem with using metal
molecules okay and then molecule I don't
know what to do with a sub molecule
right I would want molecule extract to
to do what sub graph does it seems what
is molecule I mean what else would
molecule extract do it it has hanging
flapping bonds does this have hanging I
mean I don't even know how you represent
a hanging bond right so so all of the
the molecule modifying functions that I
have ever proposed that we would have
they would be smart and they would they
would handle hydrogen's so if you had a
four carbon chain that has you know 10
hydrogen's on it when you chop off two
of them to extract them then we're gonna
put a hydrogen in the right place unless
you give the option and say there would
be options of what to do with hydrogen's
and what to do with the dangling
electrons if you chop a bond in half you
could have one electron go to each half
and you would end up with an unpaired
electron you could have both electrons
go to the extracted part that you're
taking in which case you change the
charge those would all be things that we
could that these modification functions
can do okay which modification you cut
molecule type in other other ones right
so what so then the last item the last
section is about the mother molecule
modifying we would want to so there
would be tons of things we would want to
do craft you can add replace and delete
edges vertexes vertices although the
right so the thought is instead of
having a single function for all of
these when to be honest we don't know
which are going to be the most useful
for users we have a single system level
function that takes a so if you expand
the first one and add a man the function
is molecule modify or modify molecule
takes a molecule the second argument is
a string it tells you what you're doing
and then that from that second argument
the third argument makes sense it's okay
I mean it's reminiscent of how we
control a web browser or something which
is kind of weird but yeah because at the
moment we just I mean Adam and you're
adding an atom isn't that all that
useful because you're just adding a
disconnected atom but we would still
like to have the the ability to do than
it if you're gonna have this I don't
understand why they why that molecule I
mean the the thing that applies a
permutation that applies the isomorphism
permutation should surely be another
modified molecule thing yeah that would
be a good place to put it you know
modify molecule renumber atoms or
something like that or reorder atoms and
then the permutation I'm not I mean yes
I think it's fine for you know that that
is a perfectly reasonable molecule
modification thing now this is all
different because these things mmm
these things hunt and peck and add and
subtract single atoms and so on but
whereas the sub molecule is doing
something a little different is that a
fair statement or is that or could you
put the sub molecule is the sub molecule
a very common operation
yes yes right so you've got this one
this molecule that has a it's got a
sugar and it's got a furanose ring and
you want to you want to take that and
attach it to some other molecule so so
the easiest thing would be you extract
it you end up with with a molecule that
you got back from the extraction and you
use that in your substructure replace on
another molecule oh that's beautiful
yep people often have fragment libraries
and then they can use them in different
positions in and generate virtual
libraries of molecules for what they
call in silico screening it's a shame we
can't do the same kind of things with
drops that is extracting a subgraph and
then gluing a subgraph back well can we
Roger what happens when we glue
subgraphs how do we do the renumber and
when we do subgraphs
well sub-graphs maintain where they came
from fine but in this substructure
replace somebody has to renumber some
nodes or it could get you know blown up
I don't know don't they the primary
thing is what right it's like carbon or
you know you have to label which node
it's representing a graph in the end and
the problem is that your sub structure
you know let's say you have 10 atoms in
the thing you're inserting into and
eight atoms and the substructure you're
inserting you you can't the numbering of
it has to be the numbering has to be
realigned the pointers have to be
realigned right right and so I'm asking
how these guys doing that to point to a
realignment and substructure replace I'm
guessing I mean you gotta sort of the
names fruit you have two things right
and you have to refer to addresses in
the one thing on one side and addresses
on the other thing on the other side yes
but but your molecule here on the right
hand side is not doesn't have I mean
that molecule let's imagine you said 1 2
3 arrow that molecule that molecule
itself has 1 2 3
right so you're gonna have to renumber
the one two threes in that molecule
object because they're no longer going
to be good what I'm saying
yep so what do you actually do right so
so as right now that I envision replace
sub structure you're taking the sub
structure that is atom six seven eight
and taking it out and then putting in
this whole new sub structure that has
its own bonds and there's just one
attachment but I understand that's all
one good but but nevertheless in the
specification of the graph in the sub
structure in the molecule you are
inserting that graph will have a
numbering in it wait for five for
example okay
those numbers have to be changed that
insertion time yes right so I'm asking
hmm I mean something has to change so
the assumption is the receiving molecule
doesn't have its numbers changed but the
molecule being inserted does have its
molecules does have its numbers changed
is that right yes that's what we used to
do in other modeling systems that I've
worked on rate Michaels made the point
you would if there was an atom 9 10 11
12
in the original molecule you would
expect those two to change their numbers
as well if you're old they fall down so
to speak also if you're losing
hydrogen's because you took away the
heavy atom they were attached to alright
so you're saying you're saying that you
realign I mean it's very reminiscent of
compacting garbage collectors or some
such other weird thing you're realigning
all the pointers so molecule not atom
number one if it so happened to not be
involved in the in the extraction
linker yes it's a linker right um okay
so let's talk about what the analog of
that is for graphs Roger so we don't
really have
you can't substitute a whole graph into
a graph so arguably you should be able
to where you can do the disjoint union
and then add in a you can trade yes you
can you can but but you know there
there's a whole thing that Stephen is
after really that there's not a you know
deepers if you want to do many of these
and you want to do it efficiently you
have to build different kinds of
structures to do repeated replacements
well no I understand that but it would
be good to start off by just being able
to have a struct a way of doing
replacements at all actually I think
this argues for the the molecule object
being part accessible q false and part
of what you want there Steve you know
actually what I had in mind if we were
to continue in this to just very
important to basically have a notion of
hierarchical graphs where you can
actually do abstraction there then you
need to have a clearer model so not just
a flat replacement so to speak even if
that's also interesting uh-huh and but
then you know then you have to this it
is this large set of cases to inventory
of use cases I mean of inventory cuz
there's different models of how one
might do that so for instance UML which
is based on state charts is one very
successful model of how to do
hierarchical graphs and they they're
they're more the met pond has to go
through them all you know to get sort of
a sense of what what is it what's the
meat yeah so when that when we when we
look into that the proteins and other
larger bio molecule systems would be
benefit from that from coarse graining
the the functional groups coarse
graining the the amino acids to to make
a yeah have any idea what what i mean
instead of having a vertex you'll have a
subgraph somewhere but the vertex right
but you need the trick is what is the
outside interface so that grew
no no interior and that's the trick you
know it's in the modeling business we
were calling those hairs okay it's the
universe modeling business big nose it
has a very small number of the total
headcount is very modest yeah but yeah I
think that those are you know but
they're pretty interesting you know to
to do but and in the end I think that
there's more than one answer the problem
with has I'll tell you my the issue with
has is or tentacles whatever you call
them right dangling bonds whatever you
call them right is that whereas for a
graph vertex one generally thinks that
all the and this is something again that
got messed up with with us general a
graph the graph vertex has four edges
coming into it right you think of those
edges as being you know
indistinguishable right okay um and but
in fact you might want them but by the
time you have a whole sub graph sitting
underneath there those edges clearly
aren't indistinguishable yeah actually
my point was that we need something you
know something that would be the
different modes of doing this but one
thing that we've encountered before is
sort of the notion of ports you know so
insistent modeling is that say all these
come in here that tell us we do outside
connections and then you have to specify
the wiring one level down
and the same thing for the neural net
for phonetic off right no and so the
system other business is exactly like
that
you know right so okay but so we can
call them ports has tentacles you know
whatever but the basic bottom line is
they are they might have ordering or
they might have names right
yeah well that
something we need to we need to figure
out how that's going to work um okay and
and then and then you want to define
renderings for those you know layout
schemes and typically you know that
there's another generation of of then
optimization layout schemes because then
things have size in a different way and
so then you get very closer to you know
much closer to VLSI layout kinds of
things where you actually need to take
into account size for the Lions and it's
useful to do anyway in some ways I'm
just saying it's a different level it's
a different yeah I understand do we have
an active project thinking about this
stuff no we are fully committed to
geometry so there's there's just not a
lot of going into that a lot of times
when this is done programmatically in
chemistry the fragment libraries are set
up in such a way that they're really
only being joined with two ports being
chained together or just a single port
in being attached to some substructure
that has n ports so the embedding as it
were and the size aspects are minimal to
be dealt with in other cases where it
can be much hairier as it were it's done
with a graphical editor and the chemist
has full control of placing things and
moving things around and then sighs you
know is just dealt with naturally by the
user and and the graphical interface
that they're working with and then
that's cleaned up with a geometry
optimization under some reasonable
energy model that's very similar the
system model a model of how you connect
wires together and so on yeah yeah but
system of there doesn't currently run
it's not fully autonomous layout
algorithms it's helped you but USD as a
modeler you know can control everything
okay all right let's go back okay so the
question here is we've got any
I lay out they actually that that's how
all of these EDA companies built their
business was basically solving the
layout problem right by the way just for
fun in tow an address used to have
layout girls you know so yeah but giant
sheath of miler on the floor and these
are big sheets and now you have layout
girls that draw the layouts on these
mylar sheets in the 70s into the 80s
yeah well you know when when I was doing
the stuff for the nks book I had these
graphs to detangle yeah you remember I
did I forget with you we yeah I remember
I tried to find students do it there was
this one young woman who was just
exceptionally good at at untangling
graphs and I looked her up many many
many years later and she has a company
that makes custom knitting designs so go
figure
um it's um it's really interesting
actually because she was spectacularly
much better do it you know we just gave
people these tests and she was
spectacularly much better than anybody
else at doing them and and completely
bizarrely good at them like you know I
couldn't in any way see that the graph
would untangle that way interesting
anyway but but I'm I think nowadays our
graph layout algorithms are better than
any human much better than any human and
that's probably true it's presumably
true with VLSI as well yeah and they're
they're real they're sort of performance
objectives that you have they're they're
certain speeds
you know the connectivity length
determines the speed at which the
circuit goes for instance so it's kind
of yeah and also you're you use of real
estate is kind of so they're various
things that you want to optimize in
those kinds of layouts they have
something interesting that I wanted to
introduce in future layouts for us which
is layers you know so modern VLSI
circuits have you know probably
something like 15 layers you know and
the
when you build a circuit you go you
drill a hole effectively you know cause
out of ice everything would be routes
you know like or sure I mean otherwise
you can only get a plain-out graph right
so what you're saying is that this is a
way of doing layout where things are
going to cross over but you can imagine
that there are a limited number of
layers in which the crossover occurs
because probably there's a there's
probably an easy theorem that you only
need two or three layers to do any graph
maybe even just two layers no but you
well you can can sort of compute how
many layers so you need in 3d you can
always do it I'm sure you know but but
yeah you know it's a funny thing and I
remember ever since the late 1970s
people saying you know the secret to the
future of VLSI is 3d VLSI now it's
happening
kind of is it people have said it's
happening ever since the 1970s yeah but
these what are the memory guys the what
are those memories do we have on the
phones Sims no no no they're they're
permanent memories that we are use on
the phones that we also have
at state disks for no SSDs dose they've
started both Samsung and micron are now
an Intel or building 3d layouts for
those well which are more than your 15
layers or whatever they're actually yeah
hmm yeah interesting okay we is that a
spelling mistake oh is that something
that should be added to the spelling
dictionary I think the latter I googled
and access er is used by other people
specifically in programming but yeah am
i sending it in I'll send it in okay um
okay so what we are agreeing here is
finding molecule isomorphism we're
reluctantly agreeing returns a
permutation and the question of how its
applied for right now we're thinking
molecule modify would would do that
would take reorder and atoms as a second
argument and then this is a mess
connected molecule because probably
connected golf q um right I specifically
need that check if whether I'm going to
compute 3d coordinates and I want to
know is it can connect it or not or
something so it's a it's useful
yeah and in fact if you're doing a
substructure replacement you might
forget to add you know a couple you know
connect a couple of ports that you need
to as it were and this would be a good
check to make sure that you've you know
done all the bookkeeping you need to do
so just my ignorance here but the
molecule that's not connected is that
still a molecule by I you pack
nomenclature know the the re pack
nomenclature that would can handle
everything that we are calling a
molecule is molecular molecular entity
which I just think would be terribly
confusing for us to use but so our
molecules can have a charge whereas
technically if it has a charge is not a
molecule it's an ion and our molecule
can have disconnected components okay
because we don't have a reason to
disallow them so rather spoke with with
Charles about this rather than having
all of these different things these
properties available as sub values on a
molecule we split it up some of the
properties are going to be intrinsic and
some of those are going to be more
geometric or it's sorry I don't know why
why is it not why are they not all so
bad even if some of them have to be
computed sub values and some of them are
just structurally sub values let's see
so so the point that that they're hard
to discover so some of these these sub
values when you look at the
documentation page for chemical data
it's it's huge because it has a couple
hundred properties so what and so so for
some of the some of these naturally
grouped together like the geometric
properties asking for the bond length of
a particular or what I mean so we have
autocomplete and so we have other
mechanisms for discovering what is your
solution to that that is but what does
it mean group demand to understand there
would be separate functions like there
would be geometric property there would
be molecules nobody's ever gonna
remember what they are
remember which one is which yes they'll
never remember which one is which it'll
always be you'll always have to look it
up anyway I have no idea what these peoe
VSA underscore VSA what on earth is that
right that's something surface area that
I can I will I mean when we come clearly
numb aliphatic rings isn't gonna cut it
as a name right I'm not saying that all
of these should be heads but I was
saying that they should know but not
with those crazy names I mean they've
got to be yeah anyway so look I don't
understand why you want to break these
up into it doesn't seem sensible to me
unless oh I see so here certain
properties depend on are specific to
particular atoms and other properties
are global to the molecule right correct
it's pretty much like entity poverty
like normally we can trust use entity
off string property but if you have
something really complicated with enough
qualifiers we want to form a proper
entity property that we apply fine so
why are we just calling these properties
well it's just properties I mean
couldn't we have when we have a molecule
which is in our database couldn't these
properties just actually work you know
if we say benzene you know open bracket
benzene as an entity in our database
open bracket mono isotopic molar mass
should just work as a property for that
and it would also be also work as a sub
value to a custom created molecule right
so I guess after the last meeting I was
feeling some resistance to just throwing
all of these things into the to
properties and so I thought which so at
the last you had said possibly making
formal charges a head and then I don't
know how important it is relative to all
these other things great I let's let's
see how
whole kiyah alpha doesn't I I'm sure
it's very important but I don't know
what it is um it's a graph invariant I
figured it was probably something like
that yeah but there are many golfin very
I think there are the Kappa 1 Kappa to
all of those there they're using machine
learning or regression analyses for for
various things you need to pull up these
do we yet have an encoder for molecules
I guess we don't have a molecule so we
don't have we don't have the opportunity
to have a machine learning I'm getting
an intern this summer to whose knows
more about machine learning than I do
and we're gonna try and throw something
together okay um okay so let's look at
this for a second I mean so look I
strongly think that we should try to
support those you know we should try to
combine the properties from our built in
molecules and our custom created
molecules and we should have the same
mechanism just like you can say you know
the benzene entity you know if I say
something like um you know benzene you
know molar mass or something it'll just
work I don't see why that doesn't work
on a custom molecule as well right I've
got a I took I made a list of all the
chemical data properties that can be
computed just from the structure and we
could support all of them yeah okay
great and and then the Kappa ones of
this world I don't see why we shouldn't
support those from for benzene also
right I mean it's just a question of I
mean you know if we can compute them
from a custom molecule then we just take
whatever the structure of the molecule
that we were given there and compute it
from that so we can we can pre-compute a
bunch of them I guess my fear is that
the in a list of a couple hundred
properties things can get lost
okay that's a documentation problem okay
that's a that's a separate I mean
I think for these properties we are
planning to have separate pages for
every single property and that means we
can have guide pages for properties and
all kinds of lovely things like that but
we still need some way to get them
easily in the language what do you mean
programmatically get what the list of
these properties okay but I mean if if
the properties are the same as the
properties of the chemistry entity there
are subsets not the same okay that's it
again a separate problem we can solve
some other way we shouldn't be messing
around
you know the discovery problem and by
the way why do we need to be able to do
that I mean I look discovery problem
it's like if you want you to do things
programmatically I feel like you should
always have for thematic access to
everything it should never be forced to
use it or communication page no I I
agree I agree and I mean we've got
examples my favorite example is the list
of musical instruments which I don't
know whether we ended up um you know my
suggestion was to put some of those
things in the data repository some of
these rather arbitrary lists of things
like that anyway this is not a reason to
have look we should have a single
uniform interface for extracting
properties of molecules and it should be
the you know the molecule structure sub
value the the property you're trying to
extract I think so so even if that's the
easiest way the way that it's used most
often then we would need some kind of a
head for it so molecule value what I
would propose so say you want to look at
that get that property for ten mount
molecules molecule value can take a list
of molecules and a single property and
then so so forget so forget about
geometric property and molecule
identifiers we can throw all those in
yes I think so okay and then there was
just one more topic on this that I
wanted to to touch before we left the
idea of caching 3d coordinates across
session I don't have an I don't have a
prototype of how this would be done but
I think it would be interested a problem
with that
I mean we've got other kinds of caches
that are being kept in the local object
store okay so this would be something
along lines of persistent value yes
right but persistent value stays in the
user-defined place this would be in a
system spot or something right window
maliki if it's a if the user built the
molecule its coordinates or whatever
they build about it should be envelope
you know the user store yeah we can't do
it in a system level thing that that has
two minutes but if we are doing it so
I'm talking about doings doing something
automatically so that when they enter a
molecule they quit the kernel and come
back for them absolutely it should be in
their local object store okay local
object store yeah and I think it should
be configurable that you know we could
set it to be automatic you know some
property and it would automatically save
everything is practice the function once
just does this it automatically caches
and there's a there's a version of once
that's coming I think it's even it's
probably there in 11 3 it has a second
argument which is the persistence
location which will tell you whether
it's session level persistence or
whether it's you know you can have cloud
level persistence where it will show up
in every one of your accounts and so on
you know every place where you use your
wolf mighty etc so would it be something
that we would they would have to use the
the head once no I mean we could
probably have some caching mechanism
built into these functions but
absolutely it cannot cash between users
it's got to be a single user well a user
could choose to cache it globally on
their system but we absolutely do not
want any possibility of somebody no
person a farmer company X is studying
this molecule and somehow their molecule
winds up in a cache that seen by you
know person be at pharma company why
definitely very bad I just meant that um
yeah yeah I didn't mean across across
users on on a system right so
but that caching infrastructure I mean
there's many different things that do
that so for example entities do that
right now
that's what nick has this very elaborate
entity caching system which even does
prefetching and so on that's what I was
gonna try and look at the prefetch to
see how he's doing then I would ask Nick
okay all right we've got more to discuss
here but this is all very lovely and
when do we expect I mean that the first
version of all this stuff is actually
going to be in the system I suppose that
depends on when how long we expect
before the next release not the one
that's coming right up
yeah I mean look I think in a couple of
months this can be alright I think you
should target that okay okay
okay great all right sorry I'm I'm
thinking about my next meeting here and
noticing with some the you know this
blog post that I wrote about some
[Music]
sending kind of mementos of the
civilization into space the the this
SpaceX launch that just happened had a
pre version of that put out by this
crazy organization that I'm supposed to
be an advisor to um so anyway I'm
getting distracted we should wrap this
meeting um good okay
sounds good see you guys later hey thank
you bye